Kylie Jenner taking extreme measures to
ensure her privacy meanwhile Chrissy
Teigen can't find her toilet and RuPaul
drag race all-star Morgan McMichaels is
spilling the team there is a lot to
unpack there with those headlines I know
but hi it's Thursday and Kylie Jenner is
still in hiding
okay maybe not hiding so much as lying
low nesting if you will because
apparently the mama-to-be is looking for
a little privacy for her growing family
a lot of privacy actually the 20 year
old who is expecting her first child
with boyfriend Travis Scott was spotted
at a construction site Wednesday with
mom Kris Jenner and best friend Jordan
Woods now a source tells ET that kylie
is looking for a quieter life and wants
to buy land to build a compound
according to our source Kylie wants to
build a big house with extreme privacy
with a lot of land what for
quote Conley wants to build a farm
garden and have a horse stable just take
a second picture that in there earlier
this month a source told us the beauty
mogul is keeping her personal life and
brand separate which explains why she's
been keeping a low profile during her
pregnancy and something tells me that
may carry on once the baby arrives but
we'll just have to wait and see
meanwhile pregnant Chrissy Teigen has no
problem sharing her life with everyone
on the Internet and how's this for some
TMI last night Chrissy who's expecting
her second child with John Legend rushed
to the bathroom only to find that her
toilet was missing no really Teigen
explained on Twitter I got home today
and ran to go peepee and you know when
you're so close to the bathroom so you
kind of release because you know you're
about to pee well I did that and my
toilet was gone and here's the photo
evidence guys the toilet is gone where
did it go we may never know hopefully
she's relieved herself by now because
lip-sync battle is back tonight this
time with special guest Christina
Aguilera Erika Jayne and Taye Diggs will
go head-to-head performing X Tina's hits
and here's a little taste of Tay doing
Christina's Candy Man
[Applause]
[Music]
listen you can't unsee that find out if
he takes home the championship belt
tonight on the paramount Network now if
some high-quality drag is more your cup
of tea then look no further than
RuPaul's Drag Race All Stars season
three of the vh1 series kicks off
tonight and our very own Bryce Sanders
caught up with season two queen Morgan
McMichaels about her return to the
competition pretty good for a dead did
any jaws drop when you walk into that
work room well all of them of course I
mean I'm the most beautiful thing on two
legs no of course it was good to see the
girls when we walked in and we saw
everybody and you know you kind of
measure up your competition when you get
in there and a friendly sisterly way
yeah but you're like I could kill her in
a lip-sync I might you know send her
home I could be cool with her it's an
organic thing from the girls from season
two one and three and we just didn't
care
we were just out for blood and I think
that was gonna help take me to the end
of the competition okay Alfre blood that
is intense yeah you know we're all still
friends and sisters but this is not
kumbaya corner is it is it easier or
harder to compete with Queens you know
easier better the double you know right
who would you size up as your biggest
competition myself actually
I'm my own biggest competition I'm not
worried about anybody else what kind of
Morgan are we gonna see same old good
better makeup one thing I'm not a big
fan of is diva dumb I'm gonna have to
smack that down a little bit so Savage
listen if you don't watch that show you
should be all-stars three airs Thursdays
on vh1
all right guys small we've got a special
guest stopping by the daily dedi plus
it's new music Friday so make sure
you're subscribed to e t--'s channel and
turn on those notifications all right I
got to go find Chrissy Teigen spoiler
[Music]